you've never hesitated to state your
opinions and you've just mentioned that
earlier that you you like to be truthful
and talk about socially relevant things
what is it that gives you the
willingness to to do that not all actors
are free in that they play more to
politics yes but i think i have a social
responsibility and I can't go
rabble-rousing nor can I keep quiet and
say that what can I do I'm just an act
i'm not into politics because tomorrow
when there's war i'll have to pitch in
so do i wait for a walk happen to wait
for riots and then give my comments or
talk about it even before they happen
and say please don't do it I can see
things going wrong and you're not taking
even signs and when something's wrong as
done they must be a wise they don't do
that it's not right and that's what I do
it's simple it's a very pedestrian
reaction it's not a philosophical hi bro
and then literally kind of status need
not be given to it is a very prentice
trian honest reaction to something
unethical dumb immoral I get confused
with this moral issues so i don't know
what's moral and what's immoral keeps
changing over time but ethical we we
have to be kind to each other it's it's
it's a tenet of civil civil society when
that is jeopardized I do react I'm like
the body sensors with tell you pain tip
of the finger tells you that you're
going to be touching fire so somebody
has done like that that's end of the
extremities of society which touches
fire eyes or vise I'll have to inform
the head that something is going wrong
and that's what I do
do you think that that's only helped
your career because people respect the
fact that you are willing to seek god
it's got nothing to do with a carrier
because it doesn't translate the money
it doesn't translate the money at all
probably trouble but never money
you